this show episodes that you did you know
I'm a big fan of that show you great
Rhonda shows were you playing a version
of yourself it's really funny version of
yourself you want a Golden Globe for
doing that then I got a think that must
have felt pretty sweet to get the Golden
Globe but that must've been a special
night for you it didn't suck okay
did not suck yeah that was uh you know
I'd been nominated for friends for a
couple of things and you know they
always say it's it's good just to be
nominated that's what they tell you when
you don't win yeah you know it's good
just to be nominated
yeah well and then that year I won I
gotta say it's better than being
nominated okay so so like when you win
then hold it's a whole different thing
you so you go up you make your speech
and you're freaking out because it's all
the people that you idolize are right
there in the front row right and then
you have to go backstage and there's a
whole nother press thing back there
right they interview you back there all
that so I go back and I do that and
you're answering all the questions
you're still kind of floating and then I
walk off that stage down and I run into
Sharon Osbourne yeah and I say oh my god
such a big fan of your husband's he is
so awesome yeah
and this is what she says to me with a
completely straight face she didn't take
any time like immediately she goes oh
that's great maybe after this you come
back to the house and we'll have a
threesome
she was obviously hopefully kidding that
I will tell you she was not
she was backstage when I went to Latin
Grammy and